JP, thank goodness you're okay.
>> Any reason I wouldn't be?
Say did I tell you I got
someone from the Firebase team
that offer to chat with us
about data best practices?
>> No, but
actually I think that might be just
the kind of guidance that we need.
It's incredibly important
that we get the stuff right.
Crap though, I've got Bouche Ball
game with the investors.
Do you think that you can take notes?
>> Or better yet
the developer can come over to Google.
>> Yeah.
That sounds like a player.
Want to bar the company
>> Hello and welcome.
I'm here with Abe again and
I'm joined by Puff, Puff is also
an engineer in the fire base team.
Welcome, Puff.
Thanks for having me.
So I'm trying to advise
a friend on how to correctly
come up with a database schema for
firebases.
I imagine there could be some pitfalls.
Is there an issue in getting
your schema right up front.
Now one of these Firebase really allows
you to be flexible about how you
structure your data.
And that's one of the great benefits
of using a scheme on this no SQL
database.
Unfortunately, it's also one of
the pitfalls because people tend to
not think up front of how they
need to model their data.
And that's one of the things where at
some point during the lifecycle if your
application you need to start
hammering down to structure.
You need to start validating your data.
If you don't you're going to run into
issues later with either scalability, or
especially when you're
an Android developer,
you need to start mapping your
schemaless JSON into your Java classes.
And that becomes progressively
more expensive if you make
changes later on in the cycle.
An important point thing to note about
Firebase is that when you start,
when you get a new fire base, you can
pretty much do whatever you want.
You can write in any
type of crazy structure,
you want to when you're developing,
and when you're testing.
And this is easier on web then it
is on Android where your structure
can be very, very loose, but
once you get something in your this is
what we're going with this
is how we're building.
You can lock that structure in.
And you can write schema validations and
you can make sure that the only data
in your firebase matches these rules.
>> Okay.
>> Initially, it's very free form.
But once you have you have it more
concrete about what you're building and
how you want to build it,
you can lock it in just like you
would in any other database.
So when you're developing apps and
you're first laying out your scheme,
how do you go about doing it?
Do you sketch it on paper?
Do you build, so you take some
JSON data and sort of model it?
How do you go about actually doing it?
>> I usually start with
just some some code where I
write some of the sample data.
Is that the same as you did do?
>> Yeah.
I think for sure,
if you get a little bit of
code where you start saying,
all right, here is a very loosely
defined user creation page.
Well I can start writing what
a user object looks like.
I start figuring out what I need.
And then that data can start showing up
in your Firebase right away because it's
so easy to get up and running with,
that then you can be like I need
this profile information or I need
a list of their likes or whatever.
And you can just start
very free forming,
building out your data structure.
And then once you're confident
with your structure like I
said you can lock it in.
But up until then you
can just very casually
add in things where you need to and
experiment with the structure.
For most cases, I find that works.
Sometimes if it's a very large app and
you know there's going to be
tons of different types of data in
there I'll whiteboard it out and
sketch out like, all right here is this
and this will have a list that points to
this other type of data or
something like that.
But it's much more common that
I just start playing around and
then develop a structure that way.
>> Yeah and it actually because
what you then notice is that after
you figure out your structure and
how you want to store today tell
what data you want to store mostly.
Then you start worrying about
scalability of the day time.
And that's something you
can then do later so
you now know which data you want.
Now let's think about how
we can make this scalable.
So.
But starting with some
exploratory coding and
just structuring today takes
you go is very common.
>> Great so what are some
of the biggest mistakes you
see new developers doing
when they design a schema?
>> I think people,
because firebase can have this
very complicated nested structure.
Where you can essentially mimic
any Json structure you have,
which could be users and then under
users a list of user names, and
under that each user could
have a list of their friends,
which could have a whole bunch of
profile information about them.
They could have a profile, you end
up with this very nested structure.
And that doesn't work very well in it's
very hard to be specific about your what
you're loading if you have this
very complicated deep structure.
So that nesting,
I think is a very common issue.
It does, it's not that it doesn't work,
it's just that it doesn't scale as well.
>> And also it's very natural.
You see, that lots of developers, right,
I mean most of us come from a SQL
background where we work
with relational databases.
And there you cannot do
hierarchies very easily.
So when you get to a hierarchical
database like Firebase,
it's very natural to want to start
building these nested structures,
because you've never
been able to do them.
And that's when, as Abe says, we need
to start paying attention to not overly
nesting the data, because you're
going to run into issues later on.
So you typically want to stay
relatively flat in your data structure.
And that's That's not very appealing to
developers coming from SQL backgrounds.
>> Okay do you guys have any good like
war stories some like where you give
assistance to customers that had some
hiccups because they didn't follow
best practices?
>> Yeah you don't get to a quarter of
a million developers without some war
stories so.
No what we see quite often is that
people start gathering lots of data and
long lists.
And that is fine if you
need all the data, but
one of the ones we saw was we had
a developer that was tracking couriers,
were delivering packages across the
city, and each courier was, I imagined
him being on their mopeds and their
phone was pinging the Firebase server.
So there's lots of data being generated.
And they were keeping this data in one
long list, which would last essentially
for days on end, and that would
be half a million items easily.
And they were showing
this in a dashboard and
things were sluggish in general.
It was not the performance they were
looking for, so it's like well,
okay how many items do you want to show
in this list and it turns out they
were actually showing like,
at most the last five minutes of data.
And this is one of the things that you
have to start explaining to them or
if you only want to show five minutes
of data then why are you keeping
a day's data in one big list.
Because you will have to query all of
it's to just get the top ten items.
That's a very common one we see where
people are not separating their
active data from their historical data.
And yeah, these hurt so
we see this quite often.
You have something for us?
>> Yeah, another common issue related
to that is people will go and
they'll build some application
with Firebase really quickly
because it let's you do that and
they'll start getting a ton of data.
And then they'll make one
mistake in their code and
they will clear out their Firebase.
This is not normally possible, if you're
adhering to what our best practices
that we provide in our documentation.
Which is basically that you
restrict things in your Firebase,
you say only this type
of data can exist here.
Only these people can write to this and
that.
That way when you're developing,
you don't accidentally delete
all your Firebase data.
But because we don't enforce that
because in the early like we want you to
be able to experiment and play around.
We don't know if you're trying to clear
out your Firebase because you're tired
of the structure you made.
Or if you made a mistake
in your code and
you know some bug it's cleaning it out.
So we see that a lot especially like
things like hackathon where people
are trying to write code very quickly.
And they're like,
I'll not bother with the security rules,
I won't bother enforcing a schema,
and then they make one mistake, and
they're like, where is all my data.
And the answer is, it's gone.
Luckily, we have backups for that.
We do backups of your
Firebases all the time,
and we can recover that if it's
important mission critical data.
But in general, it's a very easy mistake
to make if you're not following our best
practices and implementing security and
validation roles.
Good point.
Last one I remember is I was
talking to a game developer and
they were doing a IOS app I think,
where you got to vote on either the blue
egg hatched or the red egg would hatch.
And they were looking for okay,
so we would probably use transactions
to keep the count right?
Of who voted for what.
And this is a common one where it's like
well how many players do you get and
how often do they or
how how fast do they vote?
They had half a million in like thirty
seconds and that's typically something
where if you start doing transactions,
yeah it will not skill very
well anymore because everyone will be
hitting that same counter at that time.
So there you see that you know you need
to stare into a direction where you're
actually instead of increasing
a counter you keep the votes and
start counting them separately.
And it is always fun to explain
because yeah people are used to doing
transactions.
>> Well guys,
really appreciate your time today.
Thank you very much I'm sure that our
developer will really go take this
advice and
continue on developing their app.
>> Cool, okay.
>> Glad we could help.
>> Yeah, thanks.